I was like a pretty chubby kid growing up.
We wanted like a girlfriend
and you're like, you know,
dreamed volleys things
and we can do together
a viral New York Times article featured
36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people fall in love.
We wanted to see what would happen if
we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name is Joseph [inaudible].
I'm a USC student who studies film and
television production and he's also 100
mark ones or mark to,
nevermind.
I've been single for a couple of years
now and hoping to find somebody who
shares my passions and who I
can do the things I love with.
Okay.
Hi,
I'm Brian Joseph.
I'm briar. I'm from
Orange County, California,
and I'm currently going to
school to become a veterinarian.
I've been single for about 10 months
now and I'm ready to start dating again.
Should we pick a flavor? Sure,
yeah. Let's see. What do you prefer?
Um, I don't know. I'll help
you out a little bit. All
right. For Asbury. Sound good?
Okay.
This is good one for you.
Is there something that you've dreamed
of doing for a long time and why haven't
you done it?
Of the things that I want
to do eventually in life,
the only one that I would at all have
like the slightest bit of possibility to
do now would be to just
like kind of take off.
I'd really like to just do like the
Walter Mitty thing and just like,
oh my God, that's my favorite movie of
all time. I know I love that movie. Yeah.
That's literally what I
would like to do too. Yeah.
I always told myself as soon as I
graduate high school I just want to go
traveling up here. But that's one thing
I will hold myself to do for sure.
When did you last cry in front
of another person or by yourself
or both?
I am not too emotional.
I don't cry a lot.
I think the last time I cried was
with my sister when we were watching.
I think it was titanic.
I know that's funny but the only time I
will actually cry is if I get like super
moved in a movie.
Yeah. It's funny cause I'm like
the exact opposite where I,
I don't actually think I've
ever cried during a movie.
I've gotten like teary eyed and
clothes and I'll be like, oh wow,
I'm not to cry during a movie. And
then it just stops. And I'm like, wow,
that's sad.
There was like a period pretty much for
all of freshman year when I was just
like very bottled up.
And where's it going through a lot of
things just with like moving away from
home. I would just be like in bed and
mermaid sleeping clear across, you know,
I just really like silently like tears
coming down my face. Um, but yeah,
that was it
terrible here.
But you seem better now so that's good.
The last year was doing a good plane.
Yeah.
Ooh,
what is your most treasured memory?
Okay.
I think growing up we would always go
out to the desert and just spend like a
weekend out there. Like for Christmas
during the summer, like anytime.
And it was just so fun like being out
there because if you go out there it's
just like pure silence.
Like it's so beautiful.
I think for me,
I think this was after like one of my
first dates with my girlfriend from high
school. Um, and it was like the
first serious relationship I had.
I the only so far I guess, but same. I
was like a pretty chubby kid growing up.
And so I always like was like a little
Chubby, a weird nerd who will want it,
like a girlfriend and you're like,
you know,
dreamed of all these things
and we can do together.
But kind of thought that it would
just never happen after that.
Like first date it was like,
oh wait,
I actually have that and this
is like becoming reality.
And like I've gotten here,
unless one of those moments when you
just kind of feel like you have a good
perspective of what life is and you
kind of understand how nothing matters
except for your personal experience of
life because that's the only thing that's
real to you. Um, and at that moment that
experience was really good. Awesome.
Okay. I'm going to laugh. That's okay.
I'd say he's really sweet.
He is very intelligent,
which I find very attractive.
Honestly,
my mind went all over the place at first.
Then also I was thinking about pretty its
eyes work and just kind of focusing on
that
green. Right. Or should I put,
I'd say that she's definitely someone
who cares a lot about nature and kind of
has a spirit of adventure.
She looks at her life is like the things
that she has in front of her as opposed
to thanks Jen,
you've got behind you,
which is good cause I feel like I
probably dwell on the past too much.
I feel like I just looked into your
soul.
It's Kinda hard to over
power the nervousness,
but I felt pretty
comfortable at the same time.
He made really good eye contact and
did it make me feel awkward at all?
I definitely would.
He seems like he'd be really fun.
We share a lot of similar
interests with nature.
Uh, that was definitely one of the
more unique experiences of my life. Um,
yeah. And there are bad on a
blind date or anything before, so,
oh yeah, maybe. Yeah. I mean I think,
I think it'd be interesting
just to talk more. I don't know.
I don't think there's
anything romantic there.
But interesting just to talk about are
similar perspectives on some things you
need a little bit. It's like saying
that like to her. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean hopefully it's not offensive.
I mean I don't think, yeah,
so they asked if we go on a second date.
I'm curious.
First of all you said yes. So yeah,
I feel like I'm totally honest.
Like I'd definitely be down
to to go and talk more. Um,
I like didn't feel like a,
like a romantic spark at all or anything,
but I would definitely like, I'd like to
continue the conversation that'd be like
definitely hang out and do something fun
like go to the beach or something like
that.
That'd be really cool.
I feel like the difference between
friends and romantic interests is really
difficult to define and that's something
that I've always tried to pinpoint and
never been able to.
I would say that it was
pretty nerve wracking course.
I was really nervous,
but it was overall really good experience
and I'm really happy it happened.
Hey guys, this is Jason. This is Ian.
I just want to say thank you so much for
watching that video. Uh, here at jubilee,
we just want to create amazing content
for you. That's all about radical empathy.
So let us know what you thought
the comments below. Let us know
what, if anything is too serious to be
joked about. Question number 32. Ooh,
I like that. That's a deep one. We love
reading your comments and let us know.
As always, make sure you click
subscribe, watch more videos,
and we'll see you as next step.